la unidad básica de longitud en el
sistema métrico es el metro y para
darnos una idea de lo que es un metro
diremos que la estatura promedio del ser
humano está entre 1.5 y 2 metros
una persona de 1.5 metros es más de una
persona de estatura baja mientras que
una persona que mide 2 metros debería de
considerar estar en un equipo de
basquetbol
por ejemplo en este dibujo de leonardo
davinci podemos marcar lo que sería
aproximadamente un metro en longitud
como la distancia que abarca la amplitud
de un brazo la distancia que hay con el
brazo extendido desde la punta del dedo
medio hasta un poco más adelante el
centro del pecho ese es aproximadamente
la distancia de un metro y aquí he usado
m minúscula que es la abreviatura que se
usa para indicar metro así es que
podemos considerar que de entre los
objetos más pequeños que se pueden medir
con un metro está la estatura del ser
humano u otras medidas de su cuerpo como
la expansión de sus brazos si quieres
saber cuáles son los objetos grandes que
se pueden medir con metros estaría
considerando la altura de los
rascacielos por ejemplo este de aquí es
el edificio del empire state el cual fue
alguna vez el edificio más alto ahora es
uno de los edificios altos del planeta y
cuya altura es de 443 metros este sería
un ejemplo de objetos a gran escala que
puedes medir utilizando metros te
podrías estar preguntando qué pasa si
quiero medir longitudes que son mayores
bueno en el sistema métrico se
establecen una serie de prefijos para
referirse a múltiplos de unidades en el
caso de unidades de longitud la unidad
que es típicamente usada para referirse
a longitudes de gran escala es el
kilómetro que que lo me otro kilómetro
un kilómetro equivale a mil metros mil
metros y el kilómetro se utiliza para
referirse a grandes distancias como las
que hay dentro de las ciudades o
inclusive entre ciudades
de hecho el radio o la circunferencia de
la tierra suele expresarse en kilómetros
para darnos una idea de estas
distancias aquí tenemos un mapa de nueva
york en donde aparece una escala que nos
indica cuál es el equivalente a 5
kilómetros esta escala que aparece aquí
nos indica que en el mapa esta distancia
equivale a 5 kilómetros de hecho esto lo
indican como 5k m para indicar 5
kilómetros así es que 5k m la minúscula
m minúscula que es la abreviatura para
kilómetros 5 kilómetros que equivalen a
si un kilómetro equivale a 1000 metros 5
kilómetros equivalen a 5 x mil 5.000
metros es esta distancia de aquí si
quieres medir un kilómetro sería la
quinta parte de esto sería
aproximadamente esto de aquí esto sería
aproximadamente un kilómetro
ahora existen otras unidades en el
sistema métrico para describir
longitudes mayores de un metro y menores
de un kilómetro no son muy usadas pero
las voy a describir aquí para que
tengamos la referencia tenemos
hectómetro
hectómetro que equivale a 100 metros
100 metros y también tenemos el
de cametro
ca metro de cada metro que equivale a 10
metros y las estoy poniendo en naranja
porque no son unidades que sean tan
usadas como los kilómetros o los metros
por ejemplo nadie va a referirse a la
altura de lámpara state como 4.43
hectómetros o 44.3 de k metros esta
altura usualmente se menciona como 443
metros ahora tú podrías decir bien ya sé
ahora que puedo usar estos prefijos para
tener unidades que me permitan describir
magnitudes que son mayores a un metro
múltiplos de 10 metros o múltiplos de
100 o múltiplos de mil metros pero qué
pasa si queremos ir a escalas menores
bien el sistema métrico tiene unidades
para eso para empezar tenemos el
decímetro no es una unidad muy usada
pero vamos a ponerlo aquí decímetro un
decímetro que equivale a un décimo de
metro u otra manera poner esto es que un
metro equivale a
es decímetros que abrevia mos con
minúsculas de m como dijimos esta no es
una unidad muy usada pero si vamos una
escala más abajo tenemos el centímetro
que si se utiliza comúnmente tenemos el
centímetro centímetro y aquí el prefijo
cnri significa la centésima parte así es
que un centímetro equivale a una
centésima de metro o lo que es lo mismo
un metro equivale a cien centímetros y
si quieres imaginarte un centímetro
aquí tenemos en esta foto esta pequeña
rana en la mano de una gente
la rana mide varios centímetros por lo
que un centímetro en este dibujo es
aproximadamente esta distancia ahora si
queremos medir distancias aún más
pequeñas tenemos otra unidad y esa es el
milímetro milímetro y el prefijo mil y
quiere decir una milésima de metro una
milésima de metro o lo que es lo mismo
un metro
un metro equivale a mil
milímetros de hecho luego a poner con la
abreviatura para que nos vayamos
acostumbrando a si es que un metro es
igual a mil milímetros y para darnos una
idea de los objetos que hay en la escala
de milímetros
aquí tenemos en este dibujo unas
hormigas las hormigas miden entre 3 y 4
milímetros así es que en este dibujo un
milímetro sería aproximadamente esta
distancia esta distancia sería un
milímetro lo importante aquí es que
podemos usar distintas unidades de
medición dependiendo de lo que queramos
medir lo que es importante recordar aquí
es que el sistema métrico tenemos esos
prefijos para múltiplos de 10 que aquí
los hemos visto referidos que aquí los
hemos usado a partir de la unidad básica
de longitud el metro pero estos prefijos
también se pueden usar para otras
cantidades físicas como el volumen y el
peso si hemos visto que para longitud un
kilómetro kilo es mil kilómetros son
1000 metros
esto son 100 hectómetro 100 metros de
acá son 10
es si es una décima de cien metros es
una décima de metro sentí es una
centésima centímetro una centésima de
metro y un milímetro es una milésima de
metro